an Arizona man is being praised for a
daring Act of Bravery after he helped an
entire family Escape their burning
apartment in Phoenix now the family is
thanking the stranger who says he was
just at the right place at the right
time Michael George is here with more on
that Michael an extraordinary Act of
Courage Michelle this is incredible this
mom made what had to be an excruciating
decision with the Flames closing in she
had to drop her children out of a second
story window into the arms of a stranger
that stranger a man who's homeless
living nearby and today he's being
called a hero
Phoenix mom Claudia Jimenez woke up
Thursday morning to find Flames ripping
through her apartment with the front
door blocked she and her two young
daughters were trapped they opened my
window and I started yelling I started
yelling please someone help me like
there's a fire I can't get out through
the front I need someone to please help
me but even before firefighters arrived
help came from nearby all I see is the
ladies pull open the window and she
screaming please help me please help me
Joe Hollins a man who's Homeless was
camped out near Claudia's apartment when
his wife heard the screams Joe ran to
help Claudia who was at her second floor
window he was right underneath and he's
like yes throw your daughters out I'm
gonna catch them I'm gonna get them Joe
safely caught one-year-old Valerie then
eight-year-old Natalie then the family's
two dogs but Claudia was still inside
she didn't want to come at first she
scared she was gonna fall and I was like
I got you don't worry Joe caught Claudia
too firefighters arrived and were able
to fight back the flames and this
grateful family says they owe their
lives to Joe
it will forever be thankful with him you
know
like I said to me he was an angel
because of him were here we're alive and
my daughters are safe but Joe says he's
no hero anyone would do the same yeah
anybody would they'll build the children
and thanks to Joe everyone in that
apartment got out okay now unfortunately
Claudia and a lot of the families who
lived there loss to everything but
community members are raising money to
help them but a lot of people are saying
that Joe could use a lot of support and
people want to really honor what he did
and help him out too
to see them help him as the way that he
did in some way ironically all of them
are now homeless that's right exactly it
could happen to anybody sure can